Let me the explain the reasoning
that I use when I look at a new layout.
It looks like there's two
equally spaced columns here.
That signals to me, that
we need LinearLayout weights,
where each of these have equal weights.
So let's create
a horizontal LinearLayout.
Within this first child, we have
three vertically stacked text views,
so we have a vertical LinearLayout,
and the same goes for this second child,
which has two elements vertically
stacked on top of each other
which means we use
a vertical LinearLayout as well.
And here's the code, we created a new
list_item_forecasts_today.xml file
under the layout folder.
The code looks very similar
to list_item_forecast.
It has a horizontal LinearLayout,
as a root element.
The first child is a vertical LinearLayout
with width zero and a weight of one.
The second child is another
vertical LinearLayout
with a width of zero and a weight of one,
that way the horizontal space
will be distributed evenly
among each child.
If you go back to the first LinearLayout,
notice that we have
three TextViews within it,
for date, high temperature,
and low temperature.
We specify gravity
to be center horizontal,
so anything within the LinearLayout
will be centered horizontally.
Otherwise, by default, they would be
left-aligned to the LinearLayout.
The same applies for the
second LinearLayout.
We specify gravity to be
center horizontal so that the icon
and the weather forecast TextView
within it are also centered horizontally.